[Music]  and now  a special look at marvel studios  original series loki  maybe loki wants to mix it up is that  possible you can change  hi this variant is insubordinate  stubborn unpredictable  he's doing great you need the god of  mischief  but he's really arrogant i am loki  and i am burdened with glorious purpose  unbelievable wherever you go it's just  death destruction the literal  ends of worlds  original series streaming june 9th only  on disney plus  [Music]  uh hi hi  hello it's me um it's tom um look i'm  i'm sorry to interrupt  um i just i i um i've noticed that in  these  long superhero montages loki tends to  get  you know a bit left out even though  arguably he's incredibly heroic  himself you know coming charming  uh i could go on but but but maybe why  don't i just  prove it to you wednesdays are the new  [Music]  fridays  [Music]  you